hallo ihr lieben guckt mal was ich
gemacht habe ein ganzes flash voller
schneller blitz kekse die unglaublich
lecker schmecken ich hab's mir wirklich
ganz spontan gedacht heute ich mache
jetzt noch mal kekse in den
verschiedensten ausführungen und das
rezept ist so genial ihr braucht wenig
zeit er brauchte wenig zutaten und habe
am ende fast 100 kekse also ganz viel
spaß bei dem rezept
[Musik]
wir starten jetzt mit dem teig ich
schreibe euch einmal alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben hier unten in die video
beschreibung wichtig ist doch dass die
butter wirklich ein bis zwei stunden
vorher aus dem kühlschrank genommen wird
damit sie schön weich ist ich nehme
jetzt auch mein handrührgerät das
funktioniert natürlich auch mit der
küchenmaschine und da gebe ich jetzt
einfach alle zutaten nacheinander mit
rein also zur butter puderzucker ich
nehme es kein kristallzucker weil das
wird ein schnelles rezept und bei
puderzucker löst es sich besser auf und
wenn ihr kristallzucker nehmen würdet
dann löst er sich halt erst nach einer
gewissen zeit auf wild den ganzen tag
ruhen lassen und darauf hat sich heute
einfach da gebe ich noch dass ein mit
dazu früher das erst mal einigermaßen
und dann kommen nach und nach die drei
trockenen zutaten mit dazu
[Musik]
nachdem wir dann die trockenen zutaten
dazu gerührt habe welt ihr merken dass
es erst mal so ein bisschen flockig und
trocken aussieht dann einfach weiter
rühren irgendwann verbindet sich alles
um den letzten schritt macht sie mit den
händen und wirklich insgesamt hat das
nur zwei minuten wenn überhaupt gedauert
und ich nehme jetzt immer so ein
bisschen was weg und die können dann
selbst entscheiden möchtet ihr größere
kekse möchte dem mini kekse und dann
könnt ihr das ganze einfach zu kugeln
rollen und ich werde gleich noch damit
es halt nicht nur dieser tag ist werde
ich gleich noch mit einem holzstab ein
loch rein machen denn nach dem backen
kommen dann noch verschiedene cremes mit
rein und ihr dürft jetzt auch schon mal
entscheiden möchtet ihr sie so backen
oder möchtet ihr das mache ich gleich
nach außen rum so ein paar haselnüsse
mit rangehen kokosflocken es ist
wirklich ein super variables rezept
[Musik]
also ich habe jetzt gestartet mit
gehackten haselnüssen ich hab
kokosraspeln genommen und ich finde sie
richtig sie es aus und als nächstes habe
ich mir gedacht sind zucker zimt zucker
deshalb nehme ich mir wieder so eine
kugel und wählte sie dann ins nokia os
für eine beschreibung aber ich wollte
euch gerne mal zeigen und ihr könnt
natürlich auch alle möglichen varianten
nehmen oder noch besser schreibt man
doch jetzt mal die kommentare was ihr
noch für ideen habt denn dann kann ich
ja von euch auch mal ein bisschen
inspiration nehmen und ich denke drin
zucker sollte auch ganz gut haften
bleiben ich habe mir zwei flächen mit
wasser zur sicherheit da also hergeholt
aber es klappt wunderbar auch mit den
anderen zwei varianten hat das gut
geklappt manchmal kommen einem halt auch
ideen während des drehs und dann gebe
ich das auch einfach nur noch hier drauf
offen habe ich schon vor gehalt auf 180
grad ober und unterhitze und dann müssen
natürlich schauen wie groß sie sind wenn
sie sehr klein sind könnten sie nach
zwölf minuten schon gar sein ansonsten
ich würde glaube ich 15 minuten nicht
überschreiten so groß werden dann glaube
ich auch bei euch nicht
[Musik]
ihr könnt ihr übrigens direkt nach dem
backen die löcher noch mal ein bisschen
vertiefen denn dann sind sie noch also
dann sind die kekse halt noch ein
bisschen weicher und da habt ihr heute
noch die möglichkeit und ich werde das
ganze jetzt die gesagt befüllen nehmen
da die creme die ihr am liebsten mögen
natürlich fällt bei mir die wahl auf
meine haselnuss creme ich habe meine
schokocreme vielleicht nämlich auch die
vegane mit dazu die es einem schmeckt ja
auch noch mal ein bisschen anders und
nicht nehmen die kokons creme mit dazu
und um das ganz einfach zu befüllen
nehme ich mir jetzt einen spritzbeutel
und ich stellte mir den einfach so über
die hand und dann nehme ich mir einen
löffel und für die creme ein und vorne
werde ich ja nur noch eine ganz kleine
spitze abschneiden und das gute ist wenn
es bei euch sehr warm ist bei uns nur
schön muckelig warm im winter dann ist
die creme wenn sie auf zimmertemperatur
steht auch so cremig und so muss die
auch sein wenn ihr sie allerdings im
kühlschrank lagert dann wird sie fest
dass nutze ich aber auch als vorteil
wenn ich die kicks jetzt fülle und bitte
auch ein paar verschenken möchte dann
lager ich sie gleich auch noch mal kurz
im kühlschrank damit die creme hat
festwirt und dann könnte sie auch
übereinander stapeln und auch im schönen
boxen verstauen und allgemein finde ich
dass kik seine richtig richtig schöne
geschenkidee sind und ihr könnt mir
schreiben dass ihr dieses jahr zu
weihnachten verschenkt wir machen keine
geschenke so wirklich aber ihr könnt mir
schreiben dass ihr so verschenkt das
interessiert mich nämlich immer
[Musik]
und das ist das fertige rezepte es ging
superschnell der tag hat keine zwei
minuten gedauert rollen fertig und ich
finde das kann man auch ganz gut mit
kindern machen oder in gesellschaft man
kann einfach die verschiedensten ideen
einfließen lassen und ich würde mich
jetzt freuen wenn euch das rezept
gefallen hat dass wir da einfach ein
bisschen nach oben gibt und einfach das
in algorithmus noch mal ein bisschen
pushen und dann würde ich mal sagen wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal bzw da haben
sie das gerade nicht da aber ich lasse
ihn auf instagram probieren und werde
die sequenzen dann hier einfach
einbinden oder ihr folgt mir direkt auf
instagram also bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss
[Musik]
hier ist aus zimt zucker in hessen dann
habe ich hier haselnuss kerne ihnen
schoko hier ist kokosnuss creme und
außen kokosraspeln und das wiederholt
sich die ganze zeit noch diese reste
übrig geblieben ich hab ich mir jetzt
[Musik]
auf jeden fall schmeckt das heftig
bekämpfte bericht stolz auf dich
eigentlich muss ich noch mal so toll bis
also nichts an nach hause und dann
siehst du so was hätte er auch weiter
ich werde meine güte
hat dass ich für heute schon gereicht
[Musik]